hey guys I'm Bryce and ER and we are
live on with the cast of dirty 30
Amy and grace hello
I feel like we've been talking about
this movie for a year it we I mean we
have because I was just going through
it'll be up next week our set visit with
you guys was a year ago step of the way
you should though know how exciting is
it for to finally be out there after
talking about it for so long it's
incredibly exciting I mean 30 30 not to
toot our own horn but it's hilarious
it's great I'm just sorry people to
finally see it yeah I'm ready to birth
this thing you know what I mean my body
baby maybe is having a second okay yeah
well if you have questions about
memories baby yeah you can put them in
the comments below and I will get them
here and I will ask them but first I
watched the movie okay you think it's
you laughed the whole time like light
chuckles too heavy chuckles to a guffaw
guffaw spit-take maybe many tongues roll
on the ground like a red carpet you know
maybe on a second feeling okay yeah you
can watch it again and see a whole
different side of the movie totally
totally what is each of your favorite
part of the whole movie I mean for me
it's probably every scene that the
character Raven is in yeah Raven my goth
stock her boyfriend he looks good his
outfit was very late John TD I think
back stock will be right oh you're
welcome icing
Claire's for like my favorite yeah when
Raven is in the dance fight that happens
in the middle of the party it's a really
really fun scene my favorite
thing to watch or one of my favorite
things to watch when we were filming it
was when Hannah gets really competitive
and she goes into competition with this
character Peter who is a
larger-than-life my friend Dan
Chamberlain and just seeing how many
pushups you actually can do because you
talk a big game but I didn't know you
could walk it - yeah delivers it's The
Keg spoiler spoilers I agree you just
hold a game agree to anything yeah all
right the fan questions already rolling
in yeah Katie wants to know were you
more nervous about filming dirty thirty
or camp Takota I was actually more
pumped to film thirty thirty Dakota I
was super nervous
so nervous because it was our first film
and it's just the three of us and it
wasn't as ensemble the cast is dirty
thirty and it felt like we had had one
under our belt when we were going into
thirty thirty so yeah it felt fun you
know how tumblr does the thing where
they go freshman year versus yeah I feel
it's so relevant to the youth right
tumblr I feel like that was our freshman
year going in with your backpack like I
hope I see someone I know I hope I can
get through the day and this we're like
we're coming in exactly exactly yeah so
dirty thirty was senior year ready - 35
years ago I will say I did try and get
my character to have a bandana and this
one - yeah maybe should tie that bandana
around my neck would've been a nice
little Easter Egg all right Adrian wants
to know who breaks character the most
while you're shooting
does anybody cuz I know you guys you're
all very professional and you film this
in such a short amount of time that was
like no mistakes there was one scene
that you were doing with Dan that the
three of us are in that we all kind of
broke at different moments because he is
so he plays Peter and it's in the
kitchen
and he just kept saying hey girl sup
girls I think we just work with each
other so much we know when to shut it
down but unlike our first movie this
we're moving we're working with a lot of
funny people every day so the hardest
time for me is when I was doing a bad
date scene with Raven okay
Richard and the whole time it's the back
of my head and just his close up I mean
I think I might be a little bit of a
bobble watch out really terrible face
trying not to laugh
pull the Jamie Lee Curtis trick and stab
yourself with a thumbtack while you're
filming is that what she does she
doesn't laugh I do sometimes I pinch my
leg if I'm sitting pushes it in she goes
she goes for it committee more like less
of an artist all right Liz wants to know
did you take anything from the set oh
you know what they sent us so many party
decorations that we have the three of us
share in office yeah so we've filmed
videos the other day and we just pullin
out streamers you know what I brought
you guys mine broke oh that literally is
the poster we all sighs heads you know
managed to get the giant mamrie head
look at the camera race fact about the
memory the giant mamrie had from the
film yeah is that there's food in their
teeth bread in might like I just seen a
bagel or something and they were like we
don't need to photoshop that up feet
tall drink every time I hat falls off
during all the day so Gaga oh yeah put
on your knee and elbow maybe yeah all
right Brooke wants to know what is the
message you want people to take away
from the movie I think it is I mean
there's a lot of them but off the top of
my crazy head I would say don't be
fearful about growing older that
nothing's gonna change unless you make
it or allow it to change that you're in
charge of your own destiny and happy
no matter what what year it is yeah and
also the age ain't nothing but a number
Aliyah said that it's true though
because it's like you stress out so much
about like turning 30 and that sort of
thing and really there's there's no
other moment besides now so make sure
you're living your best now yeah don't
settle I think it's kind of a running
theme in a lot of it for your character
yeah but a lot of different storylines
in the film I think that's really
important to remind yourself and have
friends that remind you not to settle
yeah what I liked about the movie is
everybody's kind of in the same age
range but everybody's in a different
life place yeah
and how you don't have to compete with
each other you can be in your own lane
okay mine it's getting my broke hers
fell off and she has I had this bun that
I just really liked I just started
feeling like I was in modeling school I
do have to party blowers if anybody
wants these been on the floor yeah yes
but back to what you were saying that it
you can be in different lanes and not be
competitive everyone just tries to raise
each other up we feel like this is the
same with the YouTube community and that
people are doing a lot of similar things
but no one's in competition right and
it's the same in female friendships it's
true good friendships lifts you up don't
they don't let you down plus it's fun to
hang out with your friends when they're
happy so if your friends not happy like
you want to encourage them to find their
happiness so that they're more fun to
hang out with chuckling won't my own
book reserved a drink on books on
bookshelves everywhere and I stand by
this good friends are like a good bra
they lift you up and they know when to
separate
is like a sports bra they smush you down
but they're really fun and sweaty
situations and writer of the film all
right Edgar wants to know second movie
will you want to continue working
together it's so much fun there's
nothing like officially planned
you know what I'll say it's supply and
demand so by our movie yeah so we can
make more of them yeah able next Friday
the 23rd yes and I even got a target on
the 27 to buy a physical copy how cool
is that are you guys gonna go and stock
up I'm gonna pose beside ya independent
theaters that are playing it may be a
little creepy all right Amanda wants you
to describe your characters each in one
word with Charlie I'm gonna say Charlie
enthusiasm Oh mind changes throughout
the night so first I would say stagnant
and then I'd say Stella oh okay
I think evey is well-intentioned well
attention we are at our mark lifted jump
a live stream I know I want to you guys
know all right well the movie is out
next Friday go download it go to a
theater and watch it and on Tuesday go
buy a physical copy